We'll finish this lesson by talking about Correlation and Causation. We briefly
discussed this in lesson one with the Golden Arches theory of conflict
resolution which has since been disproven. But still, it's kind of funny to
think that McDonalds might cause world peace. We found this really cute cartoon
online the link is at the bottom it's a little joke that illustrates the
difference between correlation and causation. But we're leaving out the last
line because that's the punchline. First we're going to discuss correlation vs
causation. Causation means that one variable caused another to happen. For
example, the fact that it was raining caused a bunch of people to bring their
umbrellas to work. But correlation just means that there's a relationship. For
example, do happy people have more friends? Is it just because they're happy
that they have more friends? Or, does them being happy cause them to act a
certain way which then causes them to have more friends? We never know, there
are always lurking variables. We might have two variables X and Y, and they
have a relationship, but only because both of them are influenced by variable
A. Or maybe, X influences Y through variable A. A is called a mediating
variable. By just looking at scatter plots and the correlation, we don't know
what the case is. We can just see some kind of relationship. In order to make
causal statements, for one thing, the independent variable would have to occur
before the dependant variable and we have to be able to rule out any lurking
variables. With age and pets, this one's kind of easy because we know that
having more pets doesn't cause you to age. But others, like happiness and
number of friends are kind of ambiguous. Maybe having more friends causes you
to be happy or maybe being happy causes you to have more friends. We don't
know. Even if one comes before the other, this doesn't necessarily mean that
the first variable caused the second. I'm sure you can think of all sorts of
examples where that wouldn't be true.